an inmate at the Calipatria State Prison
Calipatria California to accept this
call say or dial five
now to refuse hang up now or stay on the
line for additional options do we just
get a call from prison we
did we
did had to be a wrong number or maybe I
have no idea how that happens we got a
call from a prison but there was nobody
there to press five to accept the
charges how they getting podcast in
prison maybe it's a wrong number maybe
they weren't listening to the podcast no
no no I think what happened was they
called but the answer machine is on like
we don't have somebody answering the
phone and they couldn't push or say
anything people can listen to our
podcast in prison maybe it depends on
the prison maybe it's a minimum security
I Chuck I got no idea all I know is that
we're very popular that was interesting
we're big and